Elmer is with us to start off this hour
in Harrisburg Pennsylvania hi Elmer how
are you
other days thank you for taking my call
sure what's up in your world hey I have
a question on the solar contractor and I
need some advice
one house you speak wisdom into like a
situation when a potential client is
looking to include large debt to install
their system is it better for me to just
stay out of that discussion and is there
a way that I can kind of nudge someone
into considering the you know the
challenge that they're about fate mm-hmm
well I think the thing to do you know
ethics is often solved by simply treat
other people like you don't be treated
mm-hmm that solves a lot of ethics
questions and so just switch seats okay
if you're sitting how old are you I'm 28
okay and so if you're sitting there
looking at a 21 year old just married
couple who's about to buy $30,000 worth
of solar panels on payments and you know
that that's a really stupid idea mm-hmm
you would say don't do that because
that's the right thing to do not because
solar panels are bad but because I'm
guessing that this 21 year old couple
does not need $30,000 worth of debt on
solar panels they probably don't have
the income to even discuss aborting that
right yeah so you would just look at
them and go if I was 21 how would I want
someone to treat me that was honest
switch seats and treat them that way
let's change the scenario you're dealing
with a 70 year old multi-millionaire who
wants to finance it because he believes
dad is okay and he doesn't really want
your freakin opinion right yeah this is
a crotchety old 70 year old guy who's
got serious bucks and he's gonna finance
it because he wants to and he didn't
know he wants your opinion so how would
you want to be treated if you were him
you want a 28 year old telling you how
to finance your stuff no so you would be
quiet and that would be within the
bounds of ethics right point is
that you know you can look at minor
things here's an example okay
Churchill mortgage we tell folks never
under any circumstances to take an
adjustable rate mortgage out ever right
churchill mortgage does some adjustable
rate mortgages they don't suggest them
to people that dave sent over there
because that would be inconsistent
correct but if one of the people that we
sent over there wants an adjustable rate
mortgage i haven't told churchill
mortgage they can't sell it to them
these are all adults they all get to
make their own decisions and it's kind
of funny i hear occasionally from one of
the Churchill guys some guy in Minnesota
will take out an adjustable rate
mortgage he'll say but don't tell Dave
as if they report every freaking
mortgage to me you know I mean it's
hilarious it's like the Father forgive
me for I have sinned or something you
know so you guys are all adults we get
to make our own decisions and you can
treat your customers like they're adults
but if you see someone doing something
that you wouldn't do if you were them I
think you're honor bound ethics bound to
say so very well is my question I
appreciate that yeah we do that we do
that with a lot of stuff around here I
tell people what they're supposed to do
what I think they ought to do but I
leave you room to go do what you want to
do you know you get to do it all I can
do is present to you the facts and and
love you enough to tell you what I would
do if I were you and that's how we
answer questions here on the show all
the times the same thing and so but then
you get the pick you get the choose you
have the dignity of being an adult and
choosing your own way lots of Dave
Ramsey listeners do everything I say
except cut up all their credit cards
they still carry credit card lots of
them I know you're out there I know
about you I probably have your home
address
no I'm kidding but I mean you know it's
like it's funny in it it's almost like
you have to hide it from here so that I
don't care I do care because I think
you're stupid I think you shouldn't do
that but but I'm not going to insult you
and steal your dignity as an adult
unless I and unless you're just so far
out of bound you're so far off the ranch
that you're going to hurt yourself and
then I'm gonna scream that you you're
gonna hurt yourself
and and that's just ethics do unto
others as you'd have them do unto you it
solves almost all your business ethics
questions